[Música]
a una hora de parís el castillo de
chantilly es uno de los más bellos de
francia fue construido en 1358 y sus
príncipes recibieron a louis 14 en
suntuosos banquetes en el siglo 19 rt
orleans duque de o mal restaura el
castillo y lo convirtió en un museo
excepcional que contiene la segunda
colección más grande de pinturas de
francia después de luz restauradores
jardineros y jinetes en sus salas más de
un centenar de personas trabajan cada
día para su mantenimiento
nicole garnier conservadora jefe desde
hace 24 años presenta el cuadro más
famoso del castillo este ejemplar de
rafael fue adquirido por el duque a
humala el museo conde del castillo andy
y lo restauró en 1976 es decir hace poco
y los restauradores se dieron cuenta de
que no era una copia sino un auténtico
rafael porque no nos habíamos dado
cuenta porque el barniz se había vuelto
muy oscuro estaba sucio y amarillo y fue
la encontrar este número el 133 cuando
pudimos identificar la pintura como un
original del propio maestro en la pared
del castillo cuelgan otras dos obras de
rafael las tres gracias y la virgen es
una colección excepcional que requiere
un mantenimiento constante a nicole
garnier le espera otro acontecimiento el
regreso de un cuadro recién restaurado
un paisaje italiano del pintor salvatto
rosa está bien hay suficiente espacio si
lo conseguirá pero cuidado con el
candelabro a la izquierda a la izquierda
a la izquierda cuidado con el candelabro
bien suave no lo fuerces solo agarrando
bien genial
el lienzo se vuelve a ubicar
meticulosamente en su marco
eso es lo más cuidadosamente posible
está bien buen trabajo mientras que en
el interior del museo del cuadro vuelve
a estar en su sitio en el exterior el
trabajo apenas comienza para el jefe de
jardinería thierry based este fresno
está en mal estado murió erguido y como
en los tiempos de lino cada invierno
tierra y su equipo sustituyen los
árboles muertos y drenan las zanjas
antes de volver a plantar cuando andrew
le enoja y llegó a chantilly que
encontró un pantano y como pasa con todo
pantano hay que drenar lo no era un
trabajo enorme cavar zanjas para poder
drenar el pantano tuvimos ascendió
frenaba y hoy el trabajo que hacemos es
una continuación del padrino de la
jardinería andrew de nada
todos bien chicos
en la época de andré lynott había 400
jardineros
aspirar todas estas hojas para que se
vea bonito y limpio para el fin de
semana
en la actualidad sólo 14 jardineros
trabajan en las 280 hectáreas de la
finca y cada enviar nos recogen 300
toneladas métricas de hojas muertas
restos que corren el riesgo de bloquear
las 17 fuentes del parque bien ábrelo un
poco está bajo el chorro puede haber una
obstrucción en la tubería hay una gran
diferencia en comparación con los demás
hay que subir nueve metros por encima de
los jardines del parterre para encontrar
el origen de las fuentes el basando
bronx
tierra y bassat también supervisa el
mantenimiento de este embalse que
alimenta a todas las fuentes de la
propiedad
psicosis lifting
detrás de esta puerta hay un acueducto
cubierto de siete kilómetros de longitud
originalmente traía agua potable al
castillo antes de las obras de lino
en el siglo 17 cuando andrés descubrió
este acueducto se le ocurrió una idea
decidió desviarlo hacia bastante para
para alimentar las fuentes de los
jardines del parterre de estilo francés
el agua es un elemento esencial de los
jardines franceses la obra maestra del
castillo de chantilly chantilly es
también el reino de la equitación a un
paso de las fuentes se encuentran las
mayores caballerizas de europa
construidas por el príncipe de conde en
el siglo 18
es aquí donde la directora de las
caballerizas sofía y bien aimé entrena a
sus caballos y ponis para el futuro
espectáculo ecuestre que se celebra tres
veces al año una tarea diaria en la que
participa un equipo de 30 personas
aquí está orfeo orfeó esta mañana no hay
problema nos pondremos manos a la obra
se mueve un poco lo siento ya lo veo no
importa
te lo dejo vale hasta luego mucho
trabajo por hacer esta mañana como cada
mañana los palafreneros están limpiando
las cajas de box de parking de mal sueño
al mismo tiempo voy a nuestro herrador
está aquí con su ayudante antonio para
volver a agarrar a los caballos el
cuidado de los cascos de los caballos es
la tarea diaria de guerra 2
igual que nosotros con nuestros zapatos
cuando las uñas de los pies crecen
demasiado pueden interferir en nuestra
forma de caminar o incluso hacernos
tropezar
mientras tanto sofía se maquilla y se
viste como en los tiempos de louis 14
esta es la sigue en su jaula
bien de acuerdo todo está listo entonces
podemos empezar
durante este ensayo general que dura más
de una hora sufi los demás intérpretes
repasan las rutinas de una versión
ecuestre de la bella y la bestia'
[Música]
cada año casi medio millón de visitantes
acuden a chantilly para descubrir sus
tesoros del pasado lo que supone unos
ingresos cruciales para un castillo que
gasta más de 4 millones de dólares al
año en el mantenimiento de esta joya del
patrimonio francés